thank you for coming to our talk yeah
we'll just be I guess going through a
little bit about what we're doing at
Tesco mainly so gamma and I will just
basically show two slightly different
areas of how he's in data science but in
particular with relation to how we're
designing solutions on the Tesco cluster
and stuff that actually has to be in
production and reasonably large
solutions as well with their own
challenges brief introduction so Trevor
lead data scientist in the area
forecasting at Tesco and then Guillermo
is leading the area of personalization
and recommendations for kind of online
search recommendation so a very brief
introduction to Tesco I guess pretty
much all of you will come across Tesco
it's a large company one of the largest
grocery retailers in the world kind of
top I guess from a data science point is
just nice for us because this means that
actually where we can make small
improvements this can actually have a
very large impact across quite a big
large business which is just I guess
more fun for us really as far as the
data science team there are about 40 45
I think people in now in the team
there's a mixture of people with
backgrounds much from academic so people
have gone through PhDs and postdocs and
things like that or people that have got
a lot of experience in industry I'm all
mixed together from lots of areas of
science and maths and computer science
and we need this range of different
backgrounds of people in part just
actually we get to work across the whole
of the business so we're at the
centralised group getting to do any
things from supply chain online rather
said and certain just across in stores
and everything
that so just a brief injection to this
thing onto the main part of the talk
really so I would like to talk to you
today about what we do for forecasting
now forecasting impacts the whole of a
business like Tesco be it whether you're
worrying about payroll you know how many
people you need at the store obviously
you've got the I guess the the
traditional forecast and part people
think of is supply chain you know how
much stuff do I need in store tomorrow
things like that but it really does
affect across the whole of the business
now the specific project that we were
looking at was basically how do we take
we're looking much more here at the
financial side of forecasting so what I
mean by that is things that we do that
impact
operations that start from kind of you
know weak scales out to a year and
impact things like payroll we want to do
things like budgeting so kind of making
targets for the following year and this
impacts both a store level so people
looking after stores as you can see it
so that's the the bit of the top and
then the piece at the bottom is actually
the commercial teams who are doing
buying and selling and things also have
to have sets of targets and things
they're working towards and will also
have their own sets of four costs now
the typical thing being that actually
each group of people will have their own
they will look after their area so each
say team in the commercial side will say
well I look after I know apples or you
know tin fruit or something like that
and I will know how they act and I will
make forecast for that group and you get
lots and lots of people making their own
analysis at that level separately to
that you have a like central finance for
example worrying about budgets
and maybe marketing campaigns that they
know going to be coming out through the
year and worrying about that and
separately that you have people worrying
about stores and store payroll and so
what you can end up with is quite a
disparate set of focus where actually
when you for instance if you took all of
the product group forecast and theory if
you add them all together you end up
with a top-line estate the whole of you
know Tesco forecast whereas of course
that's a completely different number to
when you at where the people have
actually made the estate forecast so how
do you actually bring all that together
and and that was mainly the kind of the
crux of this project how do we do that
and with a reasonable number of
forecasts here that we need to be making
so you know
tens of thousands in the end so the
first place we start is with
requirements so what requirements does
the business have and actually
separately what requirements do we have
a stage scientists because you know we
have other things that we need out of
these projects as well so for the
business they need a single view of all
the forecasts they need results once a
week at the beginning of the week they
would like to be you know forecasting
sales but maybe they need you know
profit or a number of items they're
selling or something else they need
sufficient accuracy so obviously we need
to work out what sufficient means and
the other bit is that whatever we
implement we don't want to throw away
expertise that is in the business so you
might think okay well we've got some
people running their separate models
each of whom will probably have a
slightly different way of analyzing
things but they also and and maybe we
can put ins and better maths but
actually in reality they have a lot of
business knowledge that you you just
don't want to be throwing away so how do
we incorporate that from the data
science side obviously we want a
solution that is easy to iterate I don't
want to do it oh I've made a four-car
system here you go and then that's it
I will need to have many developers work
the code and for something like this
which actually ends up being quite a
large project another thing that we put
in as a requirement for ourselves was we
don't want to make a forecasting system
for this specific problem we want to
make a forecasting system that we apply
to this specific problem now what that
then means is that when the next
forecasting project comes along that the
amount of work to like roll out the next
thing is is vastly reduced and then
going on from that once actually you did
get to the stage of having multiple
projects going on in forecasting how do
you actually make sure that developments
you make in one project will be
improving a different project and so
everything is working together rather
than having lots of disparate pieces of
work
first thing metrics don't particularly
one talked a long time about this but as
we know that the first thing you always
need to do in your data science project
is to work out how are you going to
measure success because if you don't you
won't you know usually basically the
project will fail because nobody has
agreed to how it succeeds and therefore
nobody ever thinks the the project has
finished or succeeds so first things
first for forecasting the we did
something that I think that's reasonably
typical is you take the mean absolute
percentage error and whereas I guess in
general machine learning you just you
choose a bit of the data and you you
take that separately for forecasting
it's important that you worry about the
time series aspect so the piece of data
that you pull apart for scoring you make
sure is effectively the end of your of
your time series so I basically I cut
off the last year's worth of data and I
simulate making rolling forecasts and
see how I would actually manage in a
real life of data that I haven't seen in
the future Romney just being a piece of
data somewhere in time
of course ways of working it was nice to
see the the talk the keynote this
morning which had a lot of this in it
actually which was good to see for us
the the thing that we have we work with
the agile process and so for those of
you do you know what it is you know what
it is and for those you don't probably
best there talk to us afterwards or on
having an introduction now but it's
useful I think one of the things that we
have found particularly key over the
past couple of years almost is changing
the data science team from a team that
makes prototypes their hands those
prototypes for engineers to making a
team that is writing the production code
with the help of engineers and one of
the key ways we found that's been very
useful for this is something called
test-driven development which again was
not in those words explained this
morning where before you write your
production code you write your tests and
how you expect staff behave and then
after that you write your code and
slowly making all your tests pass until
you have code that does what you think
it should be doing and this is just it's
a very useful way for even people who
aren't maybe used to production izing to
be making decent code that you can then
use later on we use tools like git we
code we code review so every every piece
of code that goes through a data
scientist and an engineer will both
review everything that goes through to
make sure that you've kind of you've got
both aspects of what people care about
when they're reviewing code
so - come on - actually the design of
what we did so what I want to take you
very quickly through in the next few
minutes is those iterations and the
process that we went through to come up
with our final design so that where we
started was this is all written in
Python and it's a very typical I guess
machine learning process where we've got
some data we need to do some cleaning or
data transformations to get it in to
make the data in the form that our
models will need to consume then we had
a piece of automatic model selection
there so we can actually just run a
whole different bunch of models work out
which was the best model and then we use
that for the forecasting again the way
we can score all those models is by
using that the make of the the rolling
forecast as we've put in a few other
little bits and pieces so like a small
package which just when you took in any
new time series you could just quickly
run it through and it give you know your
your typical set of graphs that are
useful for looking at that stuff
similarly for the output of the models
we didn't just output make we you know
we were worried about things like bias
and a few other metrics that were just
you know quick and easy to set see what
sorts of things were happening obviously
you would probably do more deeper dives
than those things but it just made those
quick packages to make some of the work
a bit easier for ourselves okay the
previous slide was in fact what you
would do for forecasting a single store
okay so if I want to worry about the
sales so for the coming year of a single
store the previous process now we're
going on to we want to do 3,000 stores
approximately and so what we what the
decision that we made was so we Tesco
have a cluster there are various and one
of those things that often talked about
when you have you know
your big data cluster is you need to do
something like spark ice bark or
whatever very version your caring about
and what this does is it's a way of
being able to write your your code if
that gets distributed across a cluster
of you know different cause that can
then run their different processes and
bring everything together now in theory
it's it would be a good idea if you
could write everything in PI spark so
that the the backend get sort of deal
with all that parallelization itself we
decided not to do that and the reason is
is because while PI spark is is very
good for that distribution stuff it's
not necessarily always the best thing
for your modeling part of your process
so especially for stuff like time series
or you know you want to try something
new and do something a bit different
pythons got a lot more packages and
stuff already there and things you can
worry about and maybe also some things
which don't paralyze very well anyway so
why push that so what we did is we use
PI spark as the wrapper around Python to
do the paralyzation so then we have data
processing that comes in that's all done
in the nice pie spark that you know is a
nice parallel distribution that PI spark
is excellent at and then you output a a
data frame where if you like each row of
that data frame is that is the data that
you would need for that goes into a
model so let's say the first row would
be store ones sales for the past I don't
know five years plus some information on
what I don't know the weather was doing
or what events were happening or
anything like that and that becomes a
single row and then you just apply the
Python function to every single row of
your data frame and what then happens is
PI spark uses that to now send all of my
store forecasts off to different nodes
itself so almost use pi sparked like a
queuing mechanism so then i can paralyze
ate that part bring it all back together
and do some post-processing
that was iteration number two and then I
guess getting back to more now what the
final illustration looks like so part of
so this is I guess more almost down the
processes that we needed for making
forecasting so what the first thing if
we can see we've got pipeline 1a 2a and
3a those if you would like would be I'm
gonna make forecasts at the high level
of you know the central forecasts I
would also make forecasts at a store
level so forecasting sales and I would
also make forecasts at probably eyeball
forecasts in products and I have each of
those as a different pipeline and then I
bring them together and I have to do
some reconciliation to actually make
sure they're aligned with each other now
the nice thing is they're now they're
all they're all sort of running similar
models so you do expect the numbers to
be pretty close to each other but
they're still going to be a little bit
of tweaking that you're going to need to
do to make them all actually aligned so
that's the first part secondly then that
gets passed on to what we call the early
warning system now I think this is
something which we've brought in a
little bit later but will be very
important for us going forwards now what
the early warning system is is basically
a barrage of tests on the outputs of my
forecasts that kind of encode if I was
to look at my forecast when would I
notice that they were probably wrong so
these could be things like for example
if I'm in let's say this is the
beginning of January now or something
like that and I want to forecast out for
the first week of May I would make a
forecast for that then in the second
week of January
I would rerun my forecasting algorithm
and I would again look at the first week
of May and see what that forecast is
doing now if that forecast is varying
Lots I'll go oh wait a sec maybe my
models aren't very stable what's going
on has some other day to come in I saw I
can encode that as a test and put it
into my barrage of tests for early
warning system
now the reason this is important is
because as a data scientist you're
fundamentally trying to make a data
product that you want to be able to walk
away from that project now it's not to
say that you will never be called up to
go and fix something or that you might
want to iterate it on it later on or you
might want to make improvements but you
don't want to handhold it forever you
want to be able to hand off to another
team which doesn't necessarily have data
science capabilities but maybe some
analytics capabilities or something so
by putting this in place you're you're
saying okay well this helps me make the
product we're ok if something comes out
of this early warning system that's
where you should go and look and if you
have real trouble then come and see us
and put something in our backlog and
that just helps that piece of course it
also helps with general analysis as
we're making this in the first place and
iterating after that and we have what we
call overlays and these are basically
judgmental adjustments so these
forecasts are sent off to the business
different parts of the business so the
central team will have will know some
stuff about marketing that's coming on
later in the year that we don't
necessarily have in our model the store
managers might know there's going to be
road closures in their particular stores
the guys infomercial might have noticed
also maybe some other marketing thing
that's not on a state level but kind of
a more local thing and so they can go
well you haven't you haven't captured
that there's actually no source of data
for that but we know vaguely what the
uplift is going to be or or opposite and
so we can put that on ourselves and so
you get that judgmental piece on top
which you can feed again through to the
whole system so that's what the overlays
are and what we do as far as structuring
this is we make sure that each of these
things happen separately so on once a
week I would run this thing and it would
run through the whole lot but in May but
the forecasting part takes quite a long
time but the adding the judgmental
overlay stuff doesn't so if somebody
needs to say well actually I've got some
more judgmental stuff I need to put in
they then just quickly run the last part
of the driver and job done
cool just briefly to say that you should
store all your data you can so when this
is outputting to users and stuff and
people are putting in comments that they
did find road closures
you should always shove all that back
into your data set because you never
know what you might be able to do later
on when you come back to it and you've
got some actual history of of how people
have used your forecasts and I'm just
going to quickly wrap up the session
before I pass over just to say that I
guess through all of this you can see
we've got we can do this with a signal
code base we it's very actually the way
just by that structure isn't really
specific to a certain type of
forecasting that structure works for
everything so you just need a new set of
data and maybe the exact you know
cleaning you do for a specific data set
is it specific to your forecast but you
can kind of you know work that out and
you've built most of the structure
already and yeah so we and by doing that
by running things on get we can share
models and have everywhere on the same
code base and yeah actually a project
like this does actually take quite a few
different sets of people from finance
who were who want the forecasts data
engineers making sure that any extra
data we need goes into the correct
system us as data science working with
the pipeline team who worry about the
continuous development and development
operations people writing user interface
and then you know like a project manager
and agile coach stuff kind of looking
over the whole thing so quite a big
piece together I think that's the end of
my bit and you okay so now I will show
you a little bit of a different project
where we are trying to do data science
at scale in Tesco and this one is going
to be recommendation systems I have seen
already some talks about recommendation
system in this conference and it's nice
because it's a an interesting topic that
can be applicable to many different
problems and many different sectors here
I'm not going to go into any detail
about algorithms collaborative filtering
or
this I think it has been covered here
the main points are going to be how we
are integrating a complex recommendation
system in a business so let's start
first of all with an example of
recommendations in Tesco we sell food
and these are the recommendations for
example if you search for cheese so if
you search for cheese the search engine
is going to retrieve cheese hopefully
and then we want to recommend you what
we think you may want to do next so for
example so this is a specific example or
a specific recommendation in Tesco but
well I think it will illustrate a little
bit what we do so let's start talking
about which is our environment so where
we work and then some let's talk a
little bit about our goals in terms of
our environment I think it makes sense
to split it in two different worlds
complete different worlds we have to
talk about the big data environment if
we think about recommendations we are
talking about mainly two data sources
and a transactional data where we lock
all the transactions so customer ID and
Product ID and the price of the product
at that given moment in time both for
online and in-store shops if you have
used the clutter so there we have like a
lot of information about what customers
have purchased in the past but then also
if you want to generate recommendations
for the webpage it's really useful to
take a look at clickstream data and in
clicks in data we lock all the single
interactions of a customer actors the
online journey so with the customer see
and click and add and remove a pen so
with these two data sources if you stop
and think about it and you look at the
numbers in the slide so like 10 million
daily unique customers or two thousand
every hour online sessions and from
every online session we lock all
interactions the amount of data you end
up is huge and the reason why we need to
leverage Big Data technologies on our
big data cluster in order to process all
this information so the work on the Big
Data environment I would say that is the
work of the data scientist in the saddle
with a computer and the data and they're
what we do is we process all the data we
prepare
rain sets sometimes we train our models
using big data technology some of the
times you can sample your data maybe
move the data to the cloud if you want
to elaborate GPUs or something like this
but at the end the main idea is that you
have a huge amount of data and you need
to leverage these technologies but then
of course the recommendations have to be
sheriff to the customers and have to be
served on the webpage online so if you
start thinking about complex models
where you want to run some of the
computation online so it's not only bad
processed then you have to start
thinking about a low latency serving API
or world of course we are not in charge
of the API there is an API team who is
who are the owners of this of this part
but it's interesting because it give us
some constraints so if you need to run a
model I need to run it online and you
are going to have a lot of transactions
per second then you need to ensure that
your model can run in a decent amount of
time so you can come up with the best
model in the world if it takes one
second it's not used also apart from
that it's also interesting to understand
the link between both worlds because if
we have some features that we are
creating on the big data environment but
those features have to be used on the
API side in order to serve the
recommendations you need to ensure that
both things are on sync all the time if
you deploy a model you need to ensure
that the model that you are deploying
performs exactly the same as the one you
you were training on the Big Data
Platform and so on and so forth so this
is the environment the thing is
interesting to to work with it gives
some constraints and also some
advantages as having all the data in the
big data platform once we know that
let's take a look at the goals
recommendation systems can be used for
many different purposes in your case the
main KPI or goal is to reduce friction I
don't know if you have ever tried to buy
food online in any retail but it's kind
of difficult sometimes there are a lot
of products sometimes it's difficult to
find what you are looking for if it's
too personalized and you are seeing all
the same products all the time which is
not good either so at the end one of the
main goals of having a good
recommendation system is to reduce the
friction of
the customers so they can find what they
are looking for as soon as possible yeah
it has a strongly with improving
customer experience in your opinion or
it's at least what the business think
about of course there are other KPIs
like inspiring our customers is an
important thing for Tesco we sell food
and at the end inspiring our customers
is all about helping them to discover
new recipes new ways of combining
products if you had a new product into
range or a seasonal product let the
customers find it but you have to do it
in a controlled manner if you you cannot
expand the customer with all the new
products this is the reason why it's
important to have a good recommendation
system where you understand what the
customer wants to see so you can inspire
them in a tailored way but in link
strongly linked with inspire your
customers is the profitless Capri and
also there might be other goals I have I
put here supplier promotions there can
be many so let me explain you a little
bit now of the journey we have traveled
so far in recommendation everything I
started with there was a business owner
with a problem we have a Carosa Leon
displacement and we want to improve our
recommendations there can you help us
yes we could so we said ok let's start
thinking about which data we want to use
which is pretory work we want to do and
then we find a model that we are ok with
and we think about how to serve the
recommendations we serve the
recommendations we create the value of
everybody was happy but we had an
end-to-end pipeline and after the first
use case there was a second use case and
a 30th case we said well let's stop here
take a step back every use case is
unique but they are all sharing a lot of
common things so let's take a couple of
step backs think about which are the
pieces that you can generalize and try
to attract them so we can create a
generic framework that is simple and
flexible enough so it can fits any
problem but also it's not a constraint
for future development this is the
result of that thinking process as you
can see it's very simple so what we have
here is a 2 layer framework
where we have two different stages the
first one which I can't yet generation
and the second one is a ranking model
the content generation is aiming to
narrow down from all available products
in Tesco to just a few hundreds of
products for a given customer a given
moment in time and a given business goal
so this is the context the canoe
generation will strongly depend on the
context and this is a reason why it has
two inputs all available products and a
contextual trigger that is going to
define how we want to narrow down all
those products and the reason to narrow
down all those products is that you end
up with a subset of few hundreds and you
can start training on a supervised
manner ranking model that this kind of
decouple from the conditioner ation part
and when you can maximize whatever
dimetric you you can think about if you
think about reducing friction as we will
see later you can maximize the log
likelihood of your data or whatever the
other part that I have not speak about
yet is the contextual features once you
have your product subset subset of
candidates you need to enrich those tell
us with features here is where data
scientists can be very creative and you
can think about any features you may
want to create in order to add more
information to solve the specific
recommendation for a given customer in a
specific moment in time so this is the
generic framework one of the nice things
about it is that it's very flexible as I
said so for example they can be a
generation step it can be a very complex
model like a sequence based model or it
can be a simple a use case where we want
to make recommendations for some
Valentine and we have 400 products
related with some Valentine they can
lead generation is given by the business
because we have already narrowed down
from all products in Tesco to only those
400 that are related with some Valentine
so it can be as simple as a business
rule or it can be as complex as any
model you can think about and now I
would like to illustrate this generic
framework within a specific use case
that we are doing so the problem here is
next item in basket recommendations and
so again you search for cheese and I
want to recommend you some for example
in this slide you can see like a
summarized version of a customer journey
we thought the different
on all the different locations so if we
stop at a moment given moment in time we
can see that the customer has searched
for toilet roll and we know everything
the customer has already in the basket
so far and the task is if we if we are
if we aim to reduce friction we may want
to predict what the customer was going
to do next or next or next the amount of
steps ahead you want to go is something
that depends strongly on the problem if
you only take one step ahead then this
action is going to be very correlated
with the current action if you move
further away in the future the problem
is that maybe you don't have a strong
signal to predict with so this is the
problem statement and now how we solve
it so here what we have as a contextual
trigger is a search query and a customer
we know which is the customer and we
just insert quite um let's say for
example that we're going to use here a
sequence a sequence based model where we
know what the process that you have
already in the basket and we want to
predict what what's likely to happen
next we can take the products that are
more likely to appear and say okay the
top 300 those are going to be my
candidates here in the Canada generation
the only import we care about recall
because you don't want to leave true
positives out if you leave them out they
are not going to be recommended so we
have a list of 300 products and now we
need to enrich those products with you
with features and as I said here is
where you can be very creative I have
put in the slide like five different
logical groups of features everything is
are important for our problems
personalized features is work all the
collaborative filtering you may have
heard fits into like a personalized
features can be explicit information
like how many times you can purchase a
product or it can be implicit
information how much do we think you
like the product they can be whatever
but at the end you are trying to capture
the relationship between the product
sorry between the user and each of the
products in the candidate list
replenishment cycle about whether you
need to replenish on a specific product
or not real-time features are very
important like the current price of the
basket the correct the current size of
the basket the so you can the see
of product that you have in the basket
and so on those are features that have
to be computed in real time on the API
again it's pretty cool
but it's another constraint because it's
something that takes time and takes
computational power and then of course
you service and feature based features
are just descriptors of the customer and
and the products themselves and once we
you have the this matter exists
it's a supervised problem basically you
have your matrix of features for each of
the candidates as you want to predict
which of them were indeed purchased next
so this is a very imbalance who provides
problem you can use other metrics like
pairwise loss functions doesn't matter
really is just a decision design
decision that you need to take am at the
youngest what works better for your
specific problem here I put the example
of a deep learning model like yeah deep
MLP we're just trying to maximize the
cross entropy of data and that's it
again it's going to output a probability
for each of the candidates and you can
run by the probability if you want to
think about for example now I want to
encourage my model to recommend novel
products then you can give a higher
reward if it's given higher probability
to products that fashion up in purchase
never before by that customer and so on
so now it's starting to think about how
to define a cost function that really
represents the business call of the
problem that you're trying to solve I
think that's all what I heard from my
presentation I try to be fast so yeah we
are hiding we have to stand in front of
the in front of the room yeah biggest in
serving wedding or in Farlander but yeah
if you're interested yes please come and
talk to us
there are many other products apart from
forecast or recommendation so if you if
you just want to know more please and
talk to us so that's it
there are any questions
[Applause]
so we've got five minutes for questions
or P hands up and I more for Trevor I
guess it's with respect to how you
paralyze your workflow yeah I can
understand you condensing your raw data
into a single data frame yeah did I
understand correctly then they are
running a separate Python process per
row and a data frame that's correct and
how are you doing that UDF's yeah it's
just you put your whole Python package
basically and as a UDF for each row okay
thanks anybody else thanks for the talk
same topic again how do you manage
stacking models and aggregating models
in that framework you have to kind of do
it explicitly and like we create a whole
new model which is a stack of two other
models or can you automatically you know
you say you've got like one lie GM G be
a model you've got in your network and
you actually think you might get good
results by stacking their forecasts or
by averaging them yeah once you've done
all the models what you actually do with
that oh no like I mean so it's quite
common to have a stack of models where
the output of one model goes into
another model yeah or you might
aggravate several models results to get
a better forecast sure can your can your
kind of scaling forecasting system
handle that automatically at the moment
I would say the the part where you do so
the moment we're choosing the best the
model changing that to not just choosing
the best one we're doing some ensemble
or something it's pretty easy to put in
I think the stacking of models isn't
something we've needed to do yet but I
guess again hopefully the framework is
modular enough you just pull it apart
and put bits where you need to
yeah I mean effectively what you would
have is you would have the output of a
model going into your features that goes
into that row that you then passed it
through everything so hey I was
wondering about the overlay that you
talked about yeah so on a global level
if they make a some kind of connection
to a forecast is this also reflected
down to lower levels and episodes yes
effectively we were the overlays work by
we worked out a system where how you
take any overlay and put it down to the
base unit so in this case that would be
still product group so then you can
aggregate up however you like
okay so if a local then overrides that
then it's also reflected in the
aggregated one yeah
yeah so on your product focus right so
is this some place where you capture
metadata like seasonality or trends by
product lines like new at the moment we
haven't had to worry about that
particularly and the reason is so new
stores can be a problem but effectively
we that's a completely separate process
that gets added on afterwards for the at
the moment the I said it specifically
said its product groups so for product
groups what tends to happen is if I have
a new product group that tends to be a
rearranging of the structure with maybe
one or two new products but you know if
you like on a group level if I get rid
of one product and replace it with
another product I mostly don't care it's
kind of I'll worry about well I guess
leave where do you capture things like
which products are seasonal and which
products are like are trending well
that's the model selection right so I
can I can have a model that can deal
with seasonality or a model that doesn't
care about seasonality just score them
against each other yeah and a similar
question have you looked at the Facebook
profit forecasting the fact I did have a
brief look at it I think I think it was
just we wanted to make something that
worked nicely within the Tesco
infrastructure and yeah thanks okay cool
that's all the time we have for
questions but they're gonna be there
standards right there you can ask them
questions yeah
you